.
Die Frage wird nicht alt.
Sie wird seit Jahrzehnten
immer wieder diskutiert.
Und es gibt immer
wieder traurige Anlässe,
die die Diskussion anstoßen.
Deutschland musste
schon mehrere Amokläufe erleben.
Letztes Wochenende kamen diese
grausamen Nachrichten aus den USA.
In den USA sind bei
zwei Angriffen mit Schusswaffen
insgesamt 30 Menschen getötet worden.
In Dayton, im Bundesstaat Ohio,
erschoss ein Mann neun Menschen.
Ehe er von der Polizei getötet wurde.
Wenige Stunden zuvor
hatte im texanischen El Paso
ein Täter 20 Menschen erschossen.
Nach jedem Amoklauf wird die Schuld
immer wieder bei
gewaltvollen Videospielen gesucht.
Gleichzeitig
hört man auch immer wieder:
Bzw.:
Die eine Studie widerspricht
jedes Mal der anderen Studie.
Das ist bei so einem Thema
besonders frustrierend.
Dabei ist Vieles
nur deswegen so unklar,
weil diese ganzen
wissenschaftlichen Studien
meistens zu
verkürzt dargestellt werden.
Und das möchte ich
ändern mit diesem Video.
Was sagt die Wissenschaft wirklich?
Das klären wir jetzt.
Zum Anfang würde ich gerne ein
paar Argumente vom Tisch räumen.
Die uns in dieser Debatte
definitiv nicht weiter bringen.
Es gab schon immer Gewalt,
es gab schon immer Waffen.
Mass Shootings
sind erst seit 20 Jahren häufig.
Warum? Wegen
Videospielen, sagen die einen.
Das ist
völliger Quatsch, sagen die anderen.
In Ländern wie Japan werden
viel mehr Videospiele gespielt.
Und da gibt es viel weniger Gewalt.
Weder das eine noch das
andere beweist irgendwas.
Die, die sagen, Videospiele
verursachen Amokläufe,
denn beides gibt es seit 20 Jahren,
das ist keine Begründung.
Denn in den letzten 20 Jahren
hat sich sehr viel getan.
Videospiele und Amokläufe
sind nur zwei von
unzähligen Veränderungen.
Deshalb kann man hier
auch keine Ursachen ableiten.
Für die, die sagen,
Videospiele führen nicht zu Gewalt,
denn Japan spielt
viel und ist friedlich,
das ist auch keine Begründung,
denn der Unterschied
zwischen Japan und den USA
oder zwischen Japan
und Deutschland, der ist so riesig,
Videospiele und Gewaltbereitschaft
sind nur zwei Faktoren,
von unzähligen,
auch hier kann man keine Begründung
ableiten oder ausschließen.
Auch die Feststellung,
Videospiele nehmen zu,
Gewalt allgemein nimmt ab,
stimmt zwar, ist aber leider
auch noch kein Hinweis dafür,
dass Videospiele
nichts mit Gewalt zu tun haben.
Denn allgemein abnehmende Gewalt
ist auch ein typisches Indiz
für eine Gesellschaft,
die sich weiter entwickelt.
Zum Beispiel wohlhabender
oder gebildeter wird.
Außerdem, die westlichen
Gesellschaften werden immer älter.
Ältere Menschen
sind selten gewalttätig.
Und senken so auch den Schnitt.
Solche Effekte sind
möglicherweise viel größer,
sodass man
den Einfluss von Videospielen
nicht durch den bloßen Blick
auf eine Statistik sehen kann.
Das sind alles viel
zu vereinfachte Sichtweisen,
die nicht der
komplexen Realität gerecht werden.
Und die uns so auch
überhaupt nicht weiter bringen.
Deswegen lasst
uns nicht uns mit solchen
Korrelationsfallen aufhalten,
sondern schauen wir uns mal die
Wissenschaft, die Forschung an.
Die das Ganze systematischer angeht.
Fangen wir an mit
dieser Studie aus dem Jahr 2014.
Und einem sehr schönen Beispiel
für schlechte mediale Aufbereitung.
Diese amerikanische Morning-Show
lud einen Kinderpsychologen ein.
Um über die Studie zu sprechen.
Die zu dem Schluss kommt,
Videospiele machen aggressiv.
Genauer gesagt,
häufiges
spielen gewaltvoller Videospiele
führte zu aggressiveren Gedanken.
Doch einer der Hosts bringt
einen sehr starken Einwand.
Es gebe doch keinen wissenschaftlich
nachgewiesenen Zusammenhang
zwischen Videospielen
und realer Gewalt.
Darauf antwortete Experte:
Genau das ist der Knackpunkt.
Wir sprechen
von aggressiven Gedanken,
nicht von aggressiven Taten.
Wir können nicht...
Dann wird genau
abgebrochen, Sendezeit vorbei.
Soviel zu Verkürzungen in den Medien.
Aber bereiten
wir das mal auf, denn er hat recht.
Einer der Knackpunkte
in dieser Frage ist,
wie viel hat das, was
in diesen Studien gemessen wird,
wirklich mit realer Gewalt zu tun.
Dazu müssen wir erst mal wissen,
was in dieser Studie
genau gemessen wurde.
Und ich werde nicht
müde, es zu wiederholen:
Und diese Infos findet ihr in einer
wissenschaftlichen Veröffentlichung
unter Methoden.
Hier also die Methoden
der besagten Studie.
Die Daten für diese
Studie kommen aus Befragungen
von Kindern und Jugendlichen.
Es gibt nun mal nicht für
alles physikalische Messmethoden.
Manchmal ist eine Befragung
des beste Tool, was man hat.
Und natürlich ist so eine
wissenschaftliche Befragung
systematischer durchgeführt als eine
nicht-wissenschaftliche Umfrage.
Aber trotzdem sind diese Daten
nur dann wirklich verlässlich,
wenn wir davon ausgehen,
dass diese Kinder und Jugendlichen
sich selbst
gut und ehrlich einschätzen.
Das ist die erste
wichtige methodische Info für uns.
Vorsicht
bei der Interpretation dieser Daten.
Das Gute ist, die Teilnehmer
wurden mehrfach befragt.
Über einen längeren
Zeitraum. Hier drei Jahre.
Eine Studie,
bei der man die Teilnehmer
über einen längeren
Zeitraum beobachtet, nennt man:
Wenn wir stattdessen
nur zu einem Zeitpunkt befragen,
und dabei kommt raus, diejenigen,
die viele Videospiele spielen,
sind auch gewalttätiger,
dann wissen wir immer noch nicht,
in welche Richtung
die Kausalität verläuft.
Machen die Videospiele
die Kinder gewalttätig?
Oder greifen gewalttätige Kinder
häufiger zu Videospielen?
Bei einer Längsschnittstudie
gibt es den Vorteil,
dass ich Entwicklungen
beobachten kann.
Sagen wir, in einer
Längsschnittstudie stellen wir fest,
dass eine Gruppe von Teilnehmern
im Laufe dieser drei Jahre
zunehmend häufig Videospiele spielt.
Und sie werden, zeitlich
verzögert, auch immer aggressiver.
Dann ist das ein Hinweis
auf einen kausalen Zusammenhang.
Wirklich darauf,
dass Videospiele
Aggressionen auslösen.
Für unser methodisches
Verständnis bedeutet das,
Längsschnittstudien liefern uns mehr
als nur
zusammenhanglose Korrelationen.
Aber die Aussagekraft so einer Studie
ist auch abhängig
von der Teilnehmerzahl.
Hier wurden über 3.000 Kinder
und Jugendliche befragt.
Das ist sehr solide.
Teilnehmerzahlen in den tausenden
sind ein gutes methodisches Zeichen.
Bleibt noch die Frage,
was genau wurde hier befragt?
Schauen wir uns das noch an?
Welche Videospiele spielten
die Teilnehmer, und wie häufig?
Dann wurden noch
vier weitere Sachen befragt.
Die möglicherweise mit den
Spielgewohnheiten zusammenhängen.
Aggressives Verhalten.
Haben die Kids häufig
schon mal jemanden geschlagen?
Aggressive Gedanken.
Hier mussten Kinder und
Jugendliche Fragen beantworten,
stell dir vor,
ein Junge beleidigt einen
anderen Jungen namens John.
Findest du es gerechtfertigt, wenn
John den anderen Jungen schlägt?
Oder stellst du dir manchmal vor,
jemandem,
den du nicht magst, weh zu tun?
Dann noch Empathie,
also Einfühlungsvermögen.
Und der Einfluss der Eltern.
Haben die Eltern ein
strenges Auge auf die Videospiele?
Oder eher nicht?
Jetzt, da wir endlich wissen,
wie und was alles gemessen wurde,
gehen wir noch mal
zurück zu den Ergebnissen.
Von den vier befragten Sachen,
die möglicherweise mit
Videospiel-Konsum zusammenhängen,
aggressives Verhalten,
aggressive Gedanken, Empathie,
der Einfluss der Eltern, fand diese
Studie nur einen Hauptzusammenhang.
Nämlich, gewaltvolle Videospiele
führen zu aggressiven Gedanken.
Aber:
Ich meine, jeder von uns hat sich
schon irgendwann mal gedacht:
Diesem Idioten würde
ich gerne mal auf die Nase hauen.
Ich habe so etwas
bestimmt schon mal gedacht.
Aber habe ich jemandem
schon mal auf die Nase gehauen?
Nein, denn ich mache
mich ja nicht lächerlich.
Nein, nur, weil ich mal
einen gewalttätigen Gedanken hege,
bin ich noch lange
kein gewalttätiger Mensch.
Ich habe diese Studie ausgewählt,
weil sie exemplarisch ist
für ein häufiges Missverständnis.
In vielen Studien werden nur
aggressive Gedanken beobachtet.
Und nicht aggressives Verhalten.
Trotzdem werden diese
beiden Dinge häufig vermischt.
Oder ausgetauscht, wenn
über diese Studien gesprochen wird.
Noch etwas geht in
dieser Diskussion oft unter.
Unser Verhalten und unsere Taten
werden von sehr
vielen Dingen beeinflusst.
Von außen zählen Medien
und Videospiele auch dazu.
Aber es gibt auch noch unsere
Mitmenschen und die Familien.
Und es gibt auch
noch körperliche Faktoren.
Wie zum Beispiel
die psychische Gesundheit.
Oder genetische Dispositionen.
Bei einem Video über Psychopathie
habe ich über
das Warrior-Gen gesprochen.
Die Anzahl der verschiedenen
Risiko-Faktoren für Gewalt
ist nicht nur riesig,
viele dieser Faktoren
beeinflussen sich auch gegenseitig.
Und mit dem im Hinterkopf schauen
wir uns die Studie von eben an.
Hier wurden offenbar
keine Befragungen durchgeführt.
Zu Sachen wie soziales Umfeld,
eventuelle Gewalt in der Familie.
Bildung.
All diese Einflussfaktoren, die
sicher einen großen Einfluss haben,
werden in
dieser Auswertung nicht beachtet.
Anders macht es
diese Studie aus dem Jahr 2016.
Über 9.000 Jugendliche
wurden hier befragt.
Es ergab sich ein
Zusammenhang zwischen Videospielen
und aggressivem Verhalten.
Verhalten, nicht Gedanken.
Das Schlagen anderer Personen,
mit der Absicht, ihnen wehzutun.
Aber jetzt schauten
sich die Forscher auch an,
was für ein soziales
und familiäres Umfeld
diese Jugendlichen hatten.
Hatten sie eine
gute Beziehung zu ihren Eltern?
Gab es Gewalt zu Hause?
Als die Forscher
diese Faktoren mit einbezogen,
nur Teilnehmer
verglichen mit einem ähnlichen
sozialen und familiären Umfeld,
dann verschwand der Zusammenhang
zwischen Videospielen und Gewalt.
Hier kommen die Forscher
also zu dem Schluss,
soziale und familiäre
Faktoren sind ausschlaggebend
für gewaltsvolles Verhalten,
nicht Videospiele.
Das ist nicht die einzige Studie,
die keinen Zusammenhang findet.
Aber es gibt
auch nicht wenige Studien,
die einen Zusammenhang sehen.
Nur ist der Effekt nie erschreckend.
Die Effektgrößen schwanken
zwischen sehr klein und mittelklein.
Das ist auch
wichtig für uns, zu wissen,
Studien, die sich auf den
ersten Blick völlig widersprechen,
die eine sagt,
Videospiele sind gefährlich,
die andere sagt,
Videospiele sind harmlos,
die liegen in Wirklichkeit
gar nicht weit auseinander.
Weil die Effekte meistens klein sind,
nahe bei der Mitte.
Das ist nicht verwunderlich.
Denn in der Realität tritt ein
etwaiger Einfluss von Videospielen
immer gleichzeitig auf mit
einer Reihe von anderen Einflüssen.
Das ist ein methodischer Nachteil
solcher Längsschnittstudien.
Man kann nicht einen einzelnen
Einfluss isoliert betrachten.
Ich kann mir Versuchsteilnehmer
einladen, ins Labor.
Und mache eine Testgruppe A
und eine Kontrollgruppe B.
Die beiden Gruppen
sind sich sehr ähnlich.
Die agieren auch unter
genau denselben Bedingungen.
Nur die Testgruppe A lass ich
ein gewaltvolles Videospiel spielen.
Testgruppe B nicht.
Dann vergleiche
ich die beiden Gruppen.
Schaue, ob Gruppe A
aggressiver ist als Gruppe B.
Wenn das der Fall ist, dann kann
ich diesen Unterschied ganz klar
auf das gewaltvolle
Videospiel zurückführen.
Doch auch im Labor kann man meistens
nur aggressive Gedanken messen.
Und nicht aggressives Verhalten.
Keine aggressiven Taten.
Weil es ethisch nicht vertretbar ist,
Menschen für ein Experiment
zu gewaltvollen Taten zu animieren.
Sie dürfen natürlich niemand
anderem Schaden zufügen.
Was macht man stattdessen?
Man versucht,
Aggressionen indirekt zu messen.
Und das ist sehr schwierig.
Machen wir doch
mal einen Test mit euch.
Ich zeige euch gleich
ein unvollständiges Wort,
das ihr vervollständigen sollt.
Ihr sagt das erste Wort,
das euch in den Sinn kommt.
Freunde der Sonne, beruhigt euch mal.
Alle, die hier sofort
an Gewalt gedacht haben.
Friedliebende Leute
denken natürlich an Gehalt.
Friedliebende Leute,
die auch pleite sind.
Ihr seht, wo das Problem liegt.
Die meisten von euch
haben gerade an Gewalt gedacht.
Weil wir in diesem Video die
ganze Zeit über Gewalt sprechen.
Und ihr dadurch geprimed wurdet.
D. h. noch lange nicht, dass
ihr gewaltsvolle Gedanken habt.
Oder dass dieses Video
euch aggressiv macht.
Zumindest hoffe ich das doch.
Anderes Beispiel ist die
Vervollständigung dieses Wortes.
Man könnte das mit explode
oder explore vervollständigen.
Aber wenn man gerade
ein Videospiel gespielt hat,
wo Explosionen stattfinden,
dann ist explode einfach
ein naheliegendes Wort.
Und noch lange kein Hinweis darauf,
dass man ernsthaft
aggressive Gedanken hegt.
Um uns zu erinnern,
was eigentlich die Frage ist,
um von so etwas auf
einen Amoklauf zu schließen,
das ist völlig absurd.
Aber es gibt auch noch andere Tests.
Hier sollen die Teilnehmer
das Essen einer anderen Person
mit scharfer Soße würzen.
Obwohl diese andere Person
scharfes Essen nicht mag.
Je mehr Soße man benutzt,
um die andere Person zu quälen,
desto aggressiver
wird man eingestuft.
Das ist ein Test, der
wirklich so im Labor gemacht wird.
Ich erzähle euch
noch einen zweiten Test.
Hier werden die Teilnehmer
in dem Glauben gehalten,
dass sie ein Computerspiel
gegen eine andere Person
im Nebenraum spielen.
Gegen diese Person müssen sie besser
abschneiden in Reaktionstests.
Wenn sie gewinnen, dürfen
sie die andere Person bestrafen.
Und zwar mit einem lauten,
unangenehmen Geräusch
über deren Kopfhörer.
* Lautes, elektronisches Geräusch *
Je länger man das Strafgeräusch
für den anderen wählt,
desto aggressiver wird man bewertet.
Die andere Person im Nebenraum
gibt es in Wirklichkeit gar nicht.
Da wird nicht wirklich jemand
durch laute Geräusche bestraft.
* Lautes, elektronisches Geräusch *
Sorry, ich bin offensichtlich
ein ganz aggressiver Mensch.
Ihr könnt euch jetzt
auch selbst überlegen,
wie verlässlich solche Tests sind.
Um gewaltsvolles
Verhalten vorauszusagen.
Nicht umsonst ist die Aussagekraft
dieser Tests hoch umstritten.
Das ist nicht das einzige Problem
mit den Laborexperimenten.
In einem Laborexperiment
sollten die Test-
und die Kontrollgruppe
so ähnlich wie möglich sein.
Damit wir sie
auch gut vergleichen können.
Wenn die Testgruppe
ein gewaltvolles Videospiel spielt,
die Kontrollgruppe
ein nicht-gewaltvolles Spiel,
dann sollten die beiden Spiele,
mit Ausnahme des Faktors Gewalt,
trotzdem so ähnlich wie möglich sein.
Wenn ich Counter-Strike
gegen Candy-Crush teste,
dann hat Counter-Strike
sicher mehr Gewalt,
aber das Spiel ist
frustrierender als Candy-Crush.
Allein das könnte zu mehr
aggressiven Zeichen führen.
Trotzdem gibt es Laborstudien,
die das nicht beachten.
Ein Extremfall ist diese Studie hier.
In der, Freunde, setzt euch,
ernsthaft Mortal Kombat gegen Dance
Dance Revolution getestet wurde.
Es gibt auch
methodisch starke Studien,
die auf
diese Vergleichbarkeit achten.
In dieser Studie
wurde das Spiel Unreal Tournament
so modifiziert,
dass es eine vergleichbare
nicht gewaltsolle Version
für die Kontrollgruppe gab.
Da wurde die Waffe durch
eine Art Tennisball-Gun ersetzt.
Und wenn ein anderer
Spieler erschossen wurde,
dann gab es keinen
grafischen Tod mit Blut.
Die Figur wurde
dann einfach transparent.
In einer anderen Studie
ließ man die beiden Gruppen
vergleichbare Versionen
des Spiels Team Fortress spielen.
Einmal mit Flammenwerfern,
einmal mit Rainbow-Kanonen.
Und in beiden Studien
mit dieser methodischen Sorgfalt
fanden die Forscher
keinen Zusammenhang
zwischen der Gewalt im Spiel
und aggressiven Zeichen
oder aggressiven Gedanken.
Das deutet darauf hin,
dass aggressive Gedanken
nicht auf die Gewalt
im Spiel zurückzuführen sind.
Sondern möglicherweise auf
andere Unterschiede im Spiel.
Ihr wisst jetzt sehr viel mehr
über diesen Forschungsbereich.
Aber verwirrend ist das Ganze
trotzdem noch ein bisschen.
Lass uns mal einen Strich ziehen.
Videospiele und
Medienkonsum haben einen breiten
und langfristigen Einfluss
auf uns als Gesellschaft.
Beeinflussen Videospiele unseren
sozialen Umgang miteinander?
Wie verarbeiten wir bestimmte
Spiele oder Medien eigentlich?
Wir sind keine Maschinen,
die einen Impuls kriegen,
und die dann
wie die Lemminge handeln.
Sollten Kinder und Jugendliche
gewaltvolle Spiele spielen?
Das sind alles legitime
und spannende Forschungsfragen.
Überhaupt finde ich,
dass wir aus ethischen, moralischen
Gründen mehr diskutieren sollten,
wie wir mit Gewalt in
Videospielen umgehen.
Gerade für Kinder und Jugendliche.
Aber zu behaupten, dass es eine
wissenschaftliche Beweislage gäbe
für irgendwelche
praktischen Konsequenzen,
für die Regulierung von Videospielen,
das ist schlichtweg falsch.
Vor allem die Frage,
machen Videospiele Amokläufer,
ist eine Frage, die kein seriöser
Wissenschaftler ernst nimmt.
Sondern leider nur die Medien.
Videospiele sind
keine Ursache für Amokläufe.
Wenn aber jemand Fantasien hegt,
einen Amoklauf durchzuführen,
dann können gewaltvolle
Videospiele dazu beitragen.
Aber dazu zählen
auch gewaltvolle Filme.
Dazu zählt auch reale Gewalt,
wie sie in
den Nachrichten berichtet wird.
Also nein, Videospiele
waren keine Ursache
für die kürzlichen Shootings
in El Paso und Dayton.
Diese Behauptung
ist so absurd verkürzt,
was nach diesem Video
hoffentlich klar sein sollte.
Es ist frustrierend,
dass es so viele Politiker gibt,
die das entweder nicht
wissen oder bewusst ignorieren.
Es ärgert mich so sehr,
dass die NRA,
also die amerikanische Waffenlobby,
mit diesem blöden
Pseudo-Argument Videospiele
davon ablenken kann,
dass man für jeden Amoklauf
eine fucking Waffe braucht.
Aber auch in Deutschland
ist es schädlich,
wenn wir uns von den
wirklich wichtigen Sachen ablenken.
Denn wenn Angehörige
von Gewaltsopfern fragen, warum?
Wenn wir uns fragen, wie
können wir das in Zukunft verhindern?
Dann gibt es ein paar
ganz wichtige Stellschrauben,
die Gewalt reduzieren.
Nämlich
bessere psychische Gesundheit.
Bessere Bildung.
Und die Bekämpfung von Armut.
Hier ist der Zusammenhang mit Gewalt
wissenschaftlich gut nachgewiesen.
Das sind die Probleme,
die wir lösen müssen.
Aber klar, Videospiele
zu verbieten, wäre so viel einfacher.
Nur halt keine Lösung.
Mich interessiert sehr,
was ihr zu diesem Thema denkt.
Deswegen schreibt
das gerne in die Kommentare.
Natürlich könnt ihr auch
immer gerne Themenvorschläge
für zukünftige Videos "einreichen".
Die lese ich auch sehr gerne.
Zum Schluss noch etwas ganz Anderes.
Vielen herzlichen Dank
für all eure lieben Glückwünsche
unter dem letzten Video
und auch bei Instagram.
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut.
Und Matthias auch.
Und ich spreche
fürs Baby, das Baby auch.
Ich kann mich nicht
bei allen persönlich bedanken.
Deshalb versuche
ich das jetzt auf diesem Weg.
Wirklich, vielen, lieben Dank.
Ganz viele Kekse an alle von euch.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.